you have to spin the plates because i
remember earlier in my career i spent
like three or four years on one script
because i thought that's what you do
what script was that i wrote a script
with owen wilson
and it was right after bottle rocket
which i love and uh the cables guy love
i love bottle bottles rocket just genius
and we we wrote this script about
a man who got in a drunk driving
accident but wasn't an alcoholic and his
sponsor
at aa where he was forced to go by the
courts
was riptorn
and it was
convincing him that he was an alcoholic
even though he wasn't
and this strange friendship
between them
and i worked on it for years and just
right when i was ready to go
it was no we don't want to do it
and it never happened did it ever happen
how often do they never come back or how
often do they
come back like projects that you are
they say no we're not doing this how off
cause you hear these things like
kickball
dodgeball dodge ball
and it took 12 years and the studio
didn't want to do it and they didn't
want to do it and finally after 12 years
that seems like it rarely rarely happens
when something's turned down it hangs in
there and comes back i mean we've had
that a fair amount of time super bad
took forever
i mean super red was floating around
when we were doing
freaks and geeks wow and we made it in
2006
or about six or seven uh and they had
been working on it since they were like
13 years old i mean this was their seth
and evan's dream was was this movie and
everyone said no forever
and then
other movies started succeeding
like talladega nights
and things that i was working on
and then people said what what else do
you have and so we had a trunk of
rejected projects
the other one was pineapple express
which
was only written because we couldn't
believe anyone there was no one to make
super bad and so we were like what's
more commercial than superbad oh we
could do like a stoner action movie like
what if jerry bruckheimer made a stoner
movie perfect action movie and then we
sent that around and everyone was like
now we don't like that either
then
superbad did well they were like okay
we'll do pineapple
after that so once you've proven
yourself or once you see that there's
success in this they go oh we believe in
this filmmaker we believe in this team
we'll give them this other one yeah we
get
seth and evan's
sense of humor and their style and we
see what what seth is doing on screen
and suddenly it gets a little bit
easier
and